reduced to rubble in just 12 seconds the
culmination of a long legal battle to
have these apartment blocks declared
illegal india's supreme court ordered
the demolition it also found that
authorities colluded with the developer
i feel like this is where it was very
important because this shows that
corruption should be eroded and that
this building was the living example of
corruption so it had to go
engineers say it'll take three months to
clear the 80 000 tons of debris the
court has ordered the developer to
refund the owners with interest
this case has put the spotlight on
hundreds of thousands of buyers caught
up in long legal battles one property
consultant estimates there are about a
quarter of a million incomplete homes
worth more than 20 billion dollars in
and around new delhi most of them are in
this suburb noida
this development was planned for more
than 60 000 residents
[Music]
gupta invested in a property for his
retirement eight years on construction
has barely begun
so i bought this property in 2014
thinking that i will get the position by
1617 to the max and this will add on to
my existing income so when this will add
on to my existing income whatever loans
i have taken for my house and all so i
can set them off
the government passed laws to protect
buyers in 2016 but enforcement remains
weak before that there was pretty little
regulation on the way they functioned
so the industry is actually habituated
to functioning in a certain way
in which they can ignore
almost everything or they can circumvent
almost every law
it's not the death of law there are
enough rules regulations
the developer has refunded most buyers
it says it has lost more than 60 million
dollars and has filed for bankruptcy
many hope this case will deter
developers and authorities from breaking
the law firefighter
noida india